russia's President Vladimir Putin likes
demonstrating his strength
he's also flexing his muscles in the
ongoing confrontation with the West over
Ukraine
he has gone up in the opinion polls at
home in Germany opinions about him a
mixed knot that I think he has an
inferiority complex he's pitting himself
against the West in a way that's not
without risks like a little boy playing
in a sandbox and breaking everyone
else's castles shouting I'm the biggest
I think he's great he's trying to bring
peace at the moment not an opinion
shared by the majority of Germans
sixty-five percent think poorly of him
eight percent have a positive opinion of
him and the rest are undecided on the
political stage German Russian relations
are also suffering five years ago half
of Germans thought that the relationship
between the two was okay but this has
changed dramatically 76 percent of
Germans now consider the Russian German
relationship to be damaged some 15
percent say it's still intact and nine
percent are undecided the later - you
take it to the extreme I'm worried it's
going in the direction of the Cold War
it could be better of course soon and I
think they should maintain and develop
the relationship it's important to get
along with everyone and not always be on
one side as I just did
the majority of Germans however are
still of the opinion that Russia is a
dangerous world power